hello everyone I'm happy
to be here with you today
accompanied by the Deputy Prime
Minister under she
is us
[Music]
except
begin with and without you back
exact
no we need you know
they
know it's
you man
new cugnaux  2
stephano
magic world en s
on vaccine booster
winamax hinse and our interview
booster
my
administration
if ever too late
if
you are there for your booster thank you
your children
you are approaching the time when you are going to
choose to do your first action
healthcare workers who will  be
there to give you your first
vaccinated
windows 7 is
not
genoway
we are talking about 220 million
the federal government could
with the
general cheaters has done from the beginning
you support
and a wage subsidy
is made to keep a related to your
job
in your fridge
you  keep this link with work
then its name socialist greek debt
by companies hard hit with
to help the most  the first
continuous trials
of the park a
lot of work ahead of us for
last week's
kingstree caroline
kids
with you
paterson
saga
continues
difficulty
even victim ps had almost lost everything
I am now very happy to
pass
thank you sir products hello
to all put me everything  first of all to
take advantage of the opportunity to
unfortunately with the
micron variant which is offered
pagination
despite everything we have many
gentoo
minister
leave my world
it is to vaccinate the populations have
vaccinated to continue to accelerate
administration of the beautiful dosages  is to
vaccinate our children
on this as the prime minister
abhisit
our government announced on monday
the repeal the request
yesterday the forces in the canadian armed forces
hang out or lover 200
members withdraw from their personnel
would hold said with
my colleague the minister of l  'air and
we represent screen to follow
the evolution the evaluation of the situa  public
[Music] tions
between asean
and is also also
to reduce the spread in
december
to the number of 35
to the provinces
today I am pleased to confirm
upon request our provincial partners
chat population
who will
deliver them in  december
12m delegates between
4.10
and new keep your post
pandemic
continue to protect our health and the health
of others by following the
guidance of public health
officials
mindful of caring for each other and
signed to remain hopeful this
is  as well as we will be able to
spend together doing these new
challenges of the news
is that there is no country better
than tahri than canada
I turn
thank you very much I have
everyone
thaksin
unilabs is  limited rapidx
major inkster people and business
economics
and
we have been
framing sentence may
6,
and before that in october
we going flight plan
and provision leads to higher
grants s  benefits
comes into force in
2000 and the sage law is from wenzhou
to the microphone and the new restrictions
put in place
this year and that a recovery does not
fall into the hands of being mean
for
the majority of public health to make
the decisions  and to
support them then to bring back the
mother sheep the other lovers of which it
is implicated since the beginning was a
first picket did indeed a
black man made mannschaft for us yes
while in sanaa slice of 10  $
x
3 mm
x for
if you me and what we
saw and viewer
having
specially staged
meryl
and paul walker
the start of the grudge with wim wenders
town with ben jawad and without too much the web
of knowledge is
jazz and wine
christophe nick phipps business like any
other who goes on an
expendables mission at the
end of december does
not weaken
available to companies who say themselves
and
i want to remind you that this help
a first in saint joseph old
report on the  crisis
while
also showing
ourselves to manage public finances prudently we deserve because the
same admissible it is
illegal
the best way and despite the
economic beast also has a history of beef in
high school
they
invested in
canadian that is difficult times said
catherine ashton  regret between
warwick
monique
de marco pearl jam
in the
wind at work in
cape three commission m
in fine
identical to 2009 at the
end of december we don't think
get
enough
thank you and now i think i'm
giving the floor to
mystic
falls
in april
of this debt reminded
yves
mechaka view
and speed
a witch
pathway
we know that screening tests
but not are part of the
test solution six fines for erwan built
on the microphone there are french people who have since
been using screening for more than
one hour per hour  example
but certainly he had nothing
of his c4 nova scotian federal government
that m
screening test yes massively the
provinces  had
gone into procuring
hello that it's christmas from radio canada
for
what it is, but accessibility to
pcr tests
which will not be detected
which will perhaps have the
quality of
which the provinces can
use information
not only from  equipment but
above all personnel to
administer pcr tests across the country so
it's an important game name we know that
proving
it can do given that
the
levels
of capacity of which many teeth right in canada even businesses of  care
the many people who
need care with the variant at the microphone but
the ping information
obviously we don't get a lot of
different tools that we are
realizing all these different tools for
the most
to be able to
ensure overload in our hospitals
in the  quebec
our magistrates
to come
continue
vaccine
and we pray for many many cheeses
ashton kutcher
twins a job this weekend all that jo
any time and then for
ne  uf return has always
remained well your view the first vaccine
event of the
vaccinators
this mixture country
[Music]
in the
wind at the
wells to see the cfa 2 team
I can assure you acquired a show that
transport canada
the situation is
unacceptable
that people  be in footage
in exceptions for all the other
passengers for I
'm back
on time people are making
sacrifices people are they
know
200 drawings who decides to leave like
the other ago on vacation
it's extremely
we  seeks
to all administered
from houdini
[Music]
property supporter given
fans this is
false
digital
the first question
to your
allow free sale finishing
stats it puts
[Music]
more in
four months the delivery of 35 million
tests that had  been requested by the
provinces in previous months
is this time more in January that this
cases
are provided than the
confidence that the provinces
continue to  '
be canada doing very well
looked for so much
for a few weeks this is what's
happening
here as needed
[Music]
way
in which
felt it was a quick off fast
and vaccine
and of income support  is at 9
we expect
the next question and
bow women the duty hello
[Music]
I'm going
for quebec
5 million out of the 140 million really
important test deliveries
in the last few days
and hello that said I'm going  start
answering questions too and dark
times also always add
something to it's an issue
contains discuss with us
to minimize mobility word reality
but also to
minimize disruption in our
society we know that of the
safest patients but  this time there the indices
actors the essential through also the
internet of health care so to
learn about the united states and also who
ordered the functioning of the society
so
here
it is a  challenge to find
and also for the functioning of the
company
they know know their
situation and
find a team we will continue
our discussions
isolate ourselves the confirmed cases
most
but it is sure it is a certain gain
that we are committed  who may be infected
and perhaps have come out of their isolation
it's something
[Music] a
lot to three questions first
question on the
traditionally
selection of certain names
of hunger the requests of the provinces
are
what to make sure that everything  the world be
treated fairly so its 7 series is
in box which have been shipping since
already almost since one to and it will
continue like this over the
next few weeks
with the brothers on the issue this
size of the timelines
which are being d  to be 3.6 pounds
short transition quebec this week
if
deschamps prefers confirmed delivery
must leave his name of 500 cases we have
not confirmed
if
people  we want to help josy and
others also said
maybe not
that the provinces and territories
should have favored it changed a
lot from the beginning of December
we went from an average of 7
million tests per me  who asked you on
time section delivered in December
with all the provinces and all the
territories
times is the good collaboration are
on the lookout
vis
à
vis major
indeed to the homeless
you are falling this
situation
had
he
said
the
beac
[Music]
beaten
flocks  to hide oil fetid
to
infections can be expressed in the
face of
shoeing